[Music]
on this friday night
preparing for the worst canada braces
for a fresh onslaught of covet 19 cases
something could happen to this virus who
knows something could
change as one province adjusts its back
to school plan
again from out and about to locked in
the uk's new rules for some travelers
the science of a hyperactive hurricane
season
the warnings for an intense few weeks
ahead and
fan scan people are looking for tech to
maybe
take a place of harsh enforcement major
league baseball's potential home run
solution
for spectator
[Music]
global safety with donna friesen
reporting tonight
farah nasser good evening and thank you
for joining us
canada's top doctors are giving us the
covet 19 reality check tonight
they say they're striving for a best
case scenario or what they're calling a
slow burn
where the number of cases remain low but
they are preparing for a worst-case
scenario
warning of a potential peak this fall it
is possible
that a surge in cases will coincide with
cold and flu season
and that will potentially add a strain
on hospitals and other health resources
health officials don't know exactly what
the future holds but they do
say we need to be prepared dr teresa tam
didn't
mince words today giving canadians this
warning
the idea is to plan for
something that's at least several times
worse than your previous experience
in the short term the modeling from the
federal government estimates that
the number of coven 19 cases could grow
past 127 thousand
by august 23rd and the number of deaths
could climb
past 9 100. all of this comes as anxiety
increases about potential outbreaks when
students go back to school in september
for weeks ontario premier doug ford has
been under mounting pressure to make
changes to that province's
back-to-school plan as michael couture
explains in tonight's top story
parents and educators still have lots of
questions about how
children will be protected from covet 19
when schools
reopen and watkins would normally be
soaking up the last few weeks with her
grandkids before school starts
but she'll be taking care of them in
september because the family feels the
ontario government
is rushing children back without enough
planning
maybe after the schools have
demonstrated a level of safety
then maybe more parents will be happy to
send the children back
that lack of confidence is likely why
the return to school plan has been
tweaked
thursday ontario's education minister
tried to address concerns about
ventilation in schools
spending 50 million dollars to improve
hvac in buildings
so 50 million dollars is we're not going
to look at gift horse in the mouth
but it's a drop in the bucket of what is
actually needed to ensure that these
buildings are safe
healthy and well maintained in fact
krysta wiley of the fixar schools
advocacy group
says there are 16 billion dollars worth
of repairs needed
at schools right across the province
i've already indicated a flexibility for
the first week
ontario is willing to delay the opening
of schools like in british columbia
if certain boards don't feel ready in
the name of public health
i'll work with boards if they think they
need a tad more time i know that there's
an overall broader imperative
to get kids back into class so we know
that for their wellness and their
development
and their mental health but we're going
to be flexible we're going to be
reasonable
for months politicians have pointed out
the economy can't fully restart until
parents can go to work
but first kids have to be able to go to
school
ontario's plan was rolled out in late
july
with details on remote learning
announced this week
just don't understand why it still
continues to be a bit of an afterthought
for people
ottawa school board trustee and father
mark fisher says the province should
have been planning for this
months ago it would have taken probably
a smart person 24 hours to say
what are we going to do in september
when we need to bring schools back
that's not a revelation that comes at
the end of july and august
instead he and other ontario parents
have until sunday at midnight
to decide if their kids will be heading
back to the classroom
or staying home mike lacouter global
news ottawa
one thing's for sure no matter where you
are the situation is
constantly evolving nova scotia has now
changed course
and is now going to implement mandatory
masks for grades 4 to grade 12 students
when classes return on september 8th
this changes in line with new federal
recommendations around mask wearing
and what we know about their
effectiveness to prevent the spread of
covet 19.
students won't have to wear masks when
they're sitting at their desks but they
will have to wear them in hallways and
other common areas if a two meter
distance can't be maintained
the government says ventilation systems
are being checked in schools across nova
scotia
to make sure all equipment is operating
properly and that the windows
can be opened nova scotia reported one
new case of covet 19 today after going
11 days with no
new infections in manitoba 40 more
people have tested positive
that is the highest daily total since
the start of the pandemic
both bc and alberta recorded 84 new
cases today
87 more people tested positive in quebec
and 92
in ontario in toronto health authorities
are warning patrons of a popular
downtown strip club
they may have been exposed to covet 19.
as many as 550 people who attended the
brass rail tavern
may have been in contact with an
employee who tested positive
people who had close contact with that
individual are being asked to
self-isolate
and get tested and north of toronto now
to a resort in cottage country a cluster
of cases has been linked to out-of-town
visitors
a group of families 30 people at all
traveled together to deerhurst resort
for the august long weekend
11 of the 30 have tested positive for
covet 19.
ontario's top doctor says they ignored
physical distancing
and social bubble rules
many asylum seekers have been working on
the front lines of this pandemic
now they're being given an early chance
to become permanent residents of canada
immigration minister marco mendocino
says a new program is being launched
to acknowledge the vital role they've
played in our country's fight
against coveted 19. this is an
exceptional
measure for exceptional times in
recognition
of exceptional service we deeply
appreciate the contributions
newcomers have made to canada in recent
months
normally asylum seekers have to wait for
their claims to be accepted before they
can become permanent residents
the new program waives that requirement
there are several criteria asylum
seekers must meet to qualify
exactly how many will benefit from this
program is unclear
the ban on non-essential travel between
canada and the united states has been
extended for another 30 days
as several american states battle new
outbreaks of coven 19.
the border will remain closed until at
least september 21st
the month-long ban was first imposed in
march and has been reviewed and extended
several times
as cases in the united states spike
to another border now the uk removed six
countries from its safe
travel bubble today including france
where cases are spiking
and in new zealand a country that seemed
to have eradicated the virus
there's a new outbreak that genome
testing shows originated overseas
possibly in australia or britain as
crystal commansing reports travel
restrictions are once again tightening
as worldwide infections top 21 million
when we heard the news late last night
we changed our plans and decided to come
straight home
to miss the quarantine not wanting to be
locked away
for 14 days britain's many on vacation
in nearby france sacrificed the rest of
their holidays
people hit their roads train stations
and ferry terminals things got so busy
officials told people
not to show up if they hadn't already
booked a ferry or train
the next bit that i found really
confusing is why it started at saturday
at 4am i mean that made no sense because
surely if it's bad you start it now
rather than
in a couple of days time at 4 00 am so
it just seems
completely disorganized it just seems
utterly ridiculous
there was a warning a week ago when
infection rates in france surged higher
than they've been since
may the uk government put travelers on
notice
we were expecting it last week we were
delighted to have been able to come to
france for a week
we thought we wouldn't be able to but we
have and we've had a lovely holiday
the new quarantine rules apply to anyone
returning from france the netherlands
monaco
malta turks and caicos and aruba
in retaliation france is threatening to
impose a quarantine on visitors who
arrive from the u.k
some complain saying infections aren't
that high
new zealand however is a good example of
how quickly things can change
that country went from being virus free
for more than 100 days
to extending the lockdown in auckland
our current
expectation is that by this time
the perimeter of the cluster will be
identified
will be isolated and we can move to
level two
in auckland with confidence but the
current cluster has links to four
schools and a care home leading the
prime minister to warn that the outbreak
will
grow before it slows crystal comancing
global news
london new brunswick may soon be headed
to the polls the political parties had
been negotiating a deal to delay an
election until 2022 or
after the pandemic's over but today the
liberals pulled out of the talks
accusing progressive conservative
premier blaine higgs
off unacceptable negotiating tactics
higgs says he'll take the weekend to
consider
his next steps in ontario a man is dead
an
investigation is underway after a car
exploded
in downtown kitchener it happened this
morning outside the regional courthouse
there
police say a car parked in front of the
building and it exploded
it appears an improvised explosive
device or ied may have been used
a man was found dead inside the vehicle
the investigation to this point is
revealed that the individual who's
deceased in the vehicle is possibly the
male
responsible for the explosion
police say they're searching two
properties connected to the dead man his
name
has not been released
u.s president donald trump is using a
page from his old election play book
with a
baseless conspiracy theory about
presumptive
democratic vp nominee kamala harris
i just heard that i heard it today
that she doesn't meet the requirements
and by the way the lawyer that wrote
that
piece is a very highly qualified very
talented
lawyer i have no idea if that's right i
would have thought i would have assumed
the democrats would have checked that
out before she gets chosen to run for
vice president
you'll remember trump started his first
campaign with a racist
birtherism allegation against u.s
president barack obama
and the disinformation and the
distraction has continued
this time to divert attention from his
trailing numbers
and apparent plan to make it more
difficult for americans to vote by mail
as jennifer johnson reports critics
calling an attempt
at voter suppression as americans await
another round of covet 19
financial relief a bill in the house has
hit a roadblock u.s president donald
trump
in the bill emergency funding for the
u.s postal service to handle millions of
mail-in ballots for the november
election
the president claims without proof that
will lead to fraud
millions and millions of mail-in ballots
because they can be forged they can be
captured
they can be taken yet president trump
and the first lady have requested
mail-in ballots to vote in next
tuesday's primary election in florida
democrats too are claiming fraud after
the president appointed a major donor to
the trump victory fund
lewis dejoy as postmaster general they
claim he immediately put in cost-cutting
measures to delay
mail delivery he seems to he have been
put in
to destroy the post office and certainly
make
it much harder to conduct a fair
election long time postal service
workers say mail delivery has been
disrupted
after de joy took over in june so for
us we have to completely change the
culture of the postal service was very
disheartening
a judge in pennsylvania has asked the
trump campaign for proof of potential
fraud
after officials there and in 46 other
states were warned by the u.s postal
service
it can't guarantee all ballots cast by
mail for the election
will arrive in time to be counted
experts say there's never been evidence
of widespread fraud
and questioned the president's motives
you have a president who is clearly
saying we may not be able to trust the
results of the election
this november giving himself the
possibility
that he might challenge the result if
he's defeated
in 2016 nearly a quarter of americans
mailed in their ballots yet the
president did not question the outcome
of that election
but as he trails presumptive u.s
democratic presidential candidate joe
biden in recent polls
the president has ramped up his rhetoric
on the integrity of this election
the postal union announced friday it's
endorsing biden
warning the very survival of the u.s
postal service is at stake
jennifer johnson global news washington
fortnight legal fight coming up why the
maker of the popular game is suing
two tech giants
canada's competition bureau is
investigating amazon.ca
to determine if the online retail giant
is abusing its
market dominance in this country at
issue is whether amazon.ca has been
engaging in conduct intended to
eliminate
or discipline competitors the
competition bureau will also look at
whether amazon's policies force
other companies to sell products at
lower prices on other websites
and any strategies amazon uses to
influence shopping habits
to purchase products from them versus a
competitor
forget fighting in the game world
fortnight is an illegal fight with apple
and google after the companies dropped
the popular game
from their app stores
they say fortnite's developer epic games
violated their guidelines when it
introduced a direct payment plan
that bypasses their platforms apple and
google take a 30 percent
cut from in-app sales fortnite is free
but users can make in-game purchases for
things like weapons and character
features
epic games is suing apple and google
challenging the rules
bracing for the heart of hurricane
season ahead why it could be one of the
worst
on record
you're watching global national
[Music]
people living along the u.s east coast
are keeping an eye on tropical storm
josephine which is formed in the
atlantic ocean it is the earliest
j-named storm
in history breaking the previous record
set back in 2005.
that year was the most active atlantic
hurricane season ever
eric sorenson takes a look at what we
can expect to see this year
get ready for more of this high winds
and waves barreling for north america
the first major hurricane of the season
did serious damage along the atlantic
coast earlier this month
but we are only now entering the peak
hurricane season
from mid-august through early october
we're heading into the reading to the
heart of hurricane season we've had
10 named storms with josephine just
recently named
uh and and that's way way ahead of
schedule
we're in an active cycle for tropical
storms satellite images of huge cyclonic
systems
foreshadowing the conveyor belt of
what's to come the outlook for this year
does call for 19 to 25 named storms
7 to 11 hurricanes an increasingly hot
summer builds up the opportunity for
hurricanes
but other large trends are also coming
together this year's african monsoon
season is triggering a wave train of
systems to kick off tropical storms
over in the pacific the el nino cycle is
two to seven years long but is trending
towards la
nina which can reduce the wind shear to
counter hurricanes
then there is the atlantic oscillation
this is a multi-decade phenomenon
over the surface temperature of the
entire north atlantic and it is trending
towards
warmer waters and finally there is
climate change
the atmosphere around the world is
warming and that could trigger
serious hurricanes there's a potential
for dangerous hurricane force winds
north carolina's governor earlier this
month with an all too familiar refrain
that means we must be on high alert if
it seems like every year recently has
been ripe for atlantic storms
that's because it has we have been in
one of these active phases
phases since 1995 so we're currently in
an active phase right now
as global temperatures continue to rise
more ocean water can evaporate
plus the warmer air above is capable of
holding more moisture
in 2017 hurricane harvey was a category
4 storm for winds
but was made catastrophic by the rain
more than 100 centimeters in houston
such mega storms are rare but likely to
be more frequent there are the longer
term climate change signals
which a couple of recent noaa studies do
point
to an increasing frequency of the major
hurricanes
which are categories threes fours and
fives long term
an active phase for atlantic hurricanes
short term
the right conditions for a very active
season
experts say batten down the hatches for
the next two months
eric sorensen global news toronto
we're getting a clear sense of why that
oil spill off of mauritius
is so damaging to the east african
nation's coastline
an estimated 1 000 tons of oil is
spilled from a japanese ship
and it's spreading recent satellite
images show a dark
slick that has grown more than eight
times since the ship ran aground in late
july
the oil is now polluting two nearby
protected marine ecosystems and experts
say
damage from the environmental disaster
will be huge
next the software that could be the
ticket to getting spectators
back into stadiums
it has been months since major league
athletes have heard the roar of fans
while playing to packed stadiums in
arenas
health officials say that's not likely
to change anytime soon
but some major league baseball teams are
in talks with a tech company that could
help fill
seats safely as mike delay explains fans
will only score
if they play by the rules it's nice to
see fans are having fun with the new
pandemic rules for stadiums and arenas
this guy populated an entire section
with
100 versions of himself and
epidemiologists say his clones
will likely have the same seats again
next year
i think that if you look at things
realistically we're not going to have
these
big scale events you know sports venues
concerts anything like that
in the pre-vaccine era yet there is hope
korean baseball is now allowing fans to
attend games
however capacity is maxed out at 10
the fans are all wearing masks and
sitting far apart
and korea unlike the us has handled the
pandemic well
if you pack a stadium okay even if
everybody's wearing a mask and they're
all doing it properly
it still is a risk for transmission and
that's why i think that you know you
still want to have a sparse crowd
far enough apart so that even if
somebody's not wearing a mask properly
you have a buffer zone there
can north american sports fans respect
those buffer zones
or is it a recipe for confrontation
well a california company founded by
calgarian jazz banga
is offering a solution software that
uses existing security cameras
to spot fans ignoring mask rules it's
then up to the facility operators to
determine
how to respond right so i think there's
a lot of places where people are looking
for
tech to maybe take a place of harsh
enforcement
in terms of privacy there's no facial
recognition involved it's all about the
mask
and so we just provide heat maps and
that's that's really the essence of the
feedback we give
there's no identity involved at all
banga is talking with some major league
teams but he won't say which
at this point it's all speculation mixed
with the faint hope of sports fans mike
drolie global news toronto
and that's global national for this
friday i'm farah nasser
tonight's your canada is grand lake new
brunswick east of fredericton
if you'd like to share your canada with
us please email your photos to viewers
at globalnational.com
thanks so much for watching jeff semple
will be here tomorrow until next time
take care of yourselves and each other
good night